welcome to this video and it's yacht
bird again I wonder - three squad and
let's see if we got a Queen's Indian
again it's playing that quite often
check ok we had this with a 5d five is
an interesting way to play champ the
problem here mostly is that I have no
experience with those positions
absolutely no but okay let's try try to
still play some decent moves probably
okay well here's Bishop III maybe maybe
rook see one wasn't a great idea
the b3 was kind of awkward here should
be okay but I can bishop a three I can
go to be one it's not a big deal
probably
I am having having played b3 in response
to Bishop a6 which is normal but it's
always has this drawback of the weakened
dark squares it's a very interesting the
little um finesse in the Queen's Indian
how this um wow that is really awkward
here how this little detail changes the
position 94 now I have to check that
then I don't know
95 looks very normal let's let's put
that put that on the board maybe I can
somehow get this Bishop back and then
play rook c1 this is possible he cannot
go c6 now a knight c6 is an idea maybe
even more interesting yeah of course
that's possible just going further for
the hanging pawns but I can take and
play Knight c4 maybe one night c4
immediately it's also a possibility 94
for 96
I don't know are we tricky if I take he
can maybe take with the night night see
496 is this any good I don't know it's
interesting I really don't know
Bishop c6 this is certainly a move now
96 is a threat I mean it's it's not that
you can totally ignore it
the o'night h5 could be a mafia so okay
that one interesting
I'm taking you know you know he would
always stick with the night but no I
have 94 with the tempo but see for I
know hangs okay I have to attend to that
if I go to e3 maybe his gee he's got g5
no I also there c7 okay let's not let's
not forget about that
c7 97 he will take C form
what a mess what a big mess
that's his 71-64 not sure what this
actually is
93 g5 bishop c7 then he has been queen
queen attacking the knight I have a for
though
I cannot I absolutely cannot calculate
this it might work for him I could have
played Knight to d2 or something but I
was simply hoping that I have something
here like stuff on d5 on b6 or Bishop h3
those kind of moves let's see is there
something moving the bishop is really
impossible okay then let's do that
what a game and I'm down two minutes
that's the worst part of it coming with
my time mortality fault probably
Maremma my rooks
are totally not helping in this position
I can go after 94 I don't even have a
square for the Queen and only d1 which
is really not great he can take the
baton horn oh yeah they're just bad that
was just bad Jim yeah the likelihood is
actually very high that I had a good
position there but it was so complicated
I completely lost my way and now he's
going to kill me
Queens is six or something yeah come on
let's resign that yeah right
resigns around here blacks position is
is quite shaky I think let's say around
here I don't really and maybe it's okay
I don't know but it looked very it
looked dangerous but it doesn't seem mad
okay the computer is not giving anything
for why today I've still heard it looked
it looked shaky here with all those
possibilities but I don't the computer
gives night is-3s is not not playable
which I actually did play
just because of that yeah i know i have
i have no reply I mean this Bishop
registry this leads to this is just a
bad position
he has three well coordinated pieces
against two rooks and my rooks have no
lines open have no open files
that's just excellent for black heads
winning actually yeah I hope that that
it's a bit cheeky what he has here but
maybe that's it's not true as mentioned
I don't have lots of experience with the
line maybe somewhere here I mean I
shouldn't be worse and I that that I
think it's quite clear but what is it
that I should do the compounds to go a4
in this position just making this a
little bit more stable and the b5 not
sure maybe that is right um I can also
sometimes just rock back here it's
probably then just equal I was thinking
I might I might have something but well
here the problem was I couldn't really
figure out I don't want to play a
passive move and then I went to e3 the
way I couldn't really find something
against this to be find but he really is
nothing I thought maybe there Bishop f3
or some kind of tactic or so but there
is nothing like is it looks a bit it
looks a bit awkward but there's simply
nothing my bishop is trapped okay he got
me this time thanks for watching